[Music]
what about the asian americans who have
who have come in as immigrants and all
right start out at the lowest ranks
but they tend to do better than white
people in the world right because
they're
they're doing exactly the sort of thing
i'm talking about right which is they're
they're actually
you know training and saying we're gonna
get ready we're gonna we're gonna defy
the existing class system right and uh
you know so they're gonna go
and have more capacity and more
resources and opportunities later
because of that
how do people do that how do they how do
they do that like let's say you're a
parent of an immigration kid
you just say hey study hard right school
is important education is important yeah
and they have that let's say the culture
of praising intellect
right yeah and and work ethic right
sacrificing
and sometimes to be sacrificing to
different things to give money
for extra tutoring and these sort of
things well there there's yeah that's a
really important point because some kids
well they're coming in because of
immigrants many of them have exposure
to this they come in and they know
what needs to be done perhaps in the
other place they came from whatever
country that is
and they are ready for they haven't
experienced
the north american oppression and deep
inequality
that is part of it right so if you're a
destroyer think of african americans
destroyed families
coming out of slavery right really
incapacitate look at the
drug and gun culture that teenagers
could get into really fast
uh in uh the in in canada or or
the us for example or even parts of
europe it's a cultural problem
rather than a systemic problem no no
it's systemic but that people
um the history is what matters there's a
history so
people have a history of those resorts
the reason why they are lacking the
resources
that give them that up and even the
attitude
that we must do this right whereas when
someone just
comes in suddenly and there's a there is
some culture
to that the tiger mom culture but but
it's still
it's you're bringing in a certain set of
resources to that right to me the
attitude
right seems to indicate that it's a
mental
it's a mentality problem rather than a
systemic problem because we have this
system
that produces inequality they're always
related
they're always related there's no mental
problem without a systemic material
basically
they could be they could be but sure we
can look at we can look at
almost anything through almost any lens
so i can look at this cup through a
physics a physics lens or an artistic
line sure so or marxist
right but then it's well which one is
appropriate
it's not necessarily let's apply one
lens for everything right that's what
levels of another
analysis yeah that's reasonable
absolutely yeah so we can do that just
to play devil's advocate
let's say we have a system of oppression
okay but yet the people like let's say
the japanese who were historically
oppressed too especially in the 1940s
right
tend to do better okay so is it a system
of
oppression that that stops people from
achieving success
or is it something else are there other
factors
uh no i don't think so i think it's a
system of oppression
and people that have avoided that
oppression they may so if someone comes
from japan they may have been of modest
background right
but it's still there that background is
still different
than being in the systemic race racist
world
racist capitalism world that that let's
say
minority has been for a while in
somewhere or that immediately
goes into uh a society someone arrives
from latin america
right uh dominicans in new york and they
arrive in there
right and there there's a they're
falling into a milieu
uh going to certain neighborhoods living
in certain neighborhoods right
and that's that's systemic those
neighborhoods that's a system in
operation right
and suddenly they're connecting and
they're getting the cues from those
neighborhoods
from those uh forms of life that are
that they're immediately falling into
whereas let's say someone comes from
japan they're not going into those
neighborhoods they're moving to suburbs
they're moving in some building where
this is not happening uh in queens
somewhere right
and it's just other asians that say and
other groups east asians and central
asians and so on and south asians
they're all there that are well we're
not part of this
we're not systemically affected in the
same way we may face racism
and they may face all those things but
it's not the level of oppression
and the history of a systemic uh
lacks and gaps right that the other
communities and
so they're they can use their culture in
the sense
that you're saying you're referring to
cultural fact i know what you're saying
we have a culture our kids should be
educated you know
jews the same thing as famous for that
kind of you know no matter how poor you
are we're always going to study and
you're going to study and become a
professional and that's right
and yet they're in terribly poor
situations because
um and there was anti-semitism let's say
right so yeah so there were things that
were overcome
in those contexts but it was nothing
like the level they were white
that's a big difference they were white
so they they were not treated on the
same
and they weren't for the jews and they
were also considered whites and the
italians weren't considered white right
no no
of course of course same thing the
titans faced it no exactly the same
thing but
they had the milieu that's different
then they ended the
milieu and the systemic context for them
that's
nowhere near as damaging and destructive
as the one
that uh these other groups are okay so
have faced
understand what you're saying it's
something like even though okay so white
people will do better because this
system
encourages white success implicitly
and even though there are minorities
that do better so the asians
right i think brown people are included
i think indians are included but i'm not
sure
but let's say japanese and whatever
let's just say the japanese even though
they're not white they tend to have
success
this is this somehow still doesn't
negate
the theory that there is oppression
across the board
[Music]
you